we begin with a problem Alison Bob have
a plan
however they must split up
this now requires them to communicate
from a distance to arrange the next step
they could use telephones to communicate
but there's a problem
Eve Eve is listening and she has help if
Alice calls Bob evil hear every word so
Alice decides to send a letter to Bob to
arrange a meeting spot
thus letter must be written using secret
code so it will appear meaningless to
anyone who reads it how could they agree
on the secret code without first
communicating it to each other what kind
of code should she use these problems
lie at the heart of a black art turned
science known as cryptography this
transition was fueled by warned conflict
when secrets matter most secrecy is
intimately tied to human communication
it lies behind the worldwide
communication network global financial
systems the internet phone calls
everything we might want to hide to tell
the story we must first travel back in
time and visit two important ideas
numbers and probability these concepts
are deeply linked to survival and
gambling